helena is a 20 year old astronaut who
has lived almost her entire life in a
spaceship named orbiter 9. because of
factors like overpopulation global
warming and a toxic environment
scientists on earth have centered on a
mission to the supposed habitable planet
celeste it is believed that it will take
her more than 20 years to reach the
planet initially an infant helena was
brought to the spaceship by her parents
and they raised her there however three
years back a malfunction in the system
caused the orbiter 9's oxygen supply to
deplete at a rapid rate hence her
parents took the tough decision to
commit the unthinkable so that their
daughter could have enough oxygen to
reach the nearest outpost in this way
helena has spent the last three years
alone on the space ship her daily
routine consists of watering her veggies
exercising checking her health status
and reminiscing about her parents by
this time she has even started having
difficulties in breathing as the oxygen
supply is almost up one day the alarm in
the spaceship starts blaring and this
worries helena as it is the first time
she has experienced such an event she
immediately heads over to the control
room to inspect and finds out that a
shuttle has adjoined her spaceship it
turns out that her distress call has
finally been answered helena rushes to
the entrance and when the door opens an
engineer named alex enters she is
equally stunned and happy to see him as
it has been three years since her last
interaction with someone alex introduces
himself and proceeds to examine the
oxygen system but helena can't take her
eyes off of him possibly because she has
never seen a man her age before a few
hours later as alex is busy with the
repairs helena invites him for dinner to
which he agrees later during dinner
helena keeps asking a lot of questions
but for some reason alex is cold he
simply mentions that he has to finish
his work and return to his outpost alex
is a boy in space the next day alex
successfully repairs the oxygen system
and prepares to leave that night while
he is sleeping helena silently enters
his room and gets on top of him as she
is busy staring alex wakes up and asks
her to get down but helena who has been
alone her entire life mentions that it
might be another 20 years before she
sees someone again she then slowly
kisses him and soon the two have coitus
the following morning alex packs all his
belongings and departs without even
bidding helena a proper goodbye after
leaving the spaceship he enters a
strange hallway and then makes his way
upstairs surprisingly he comes out of
what appears to be a bunker which is
placed in the middle of the woods here
we get to know that the orbiter 9 is not
a spaceship after all and the entire
thing is being staged on earth in the
next scene alex gets in his truck and
drives through the woods which appear to
be a top secret facility we can clearly
see that there are more bunkers like
helena's and the entire operation is
known as project orbiter it's like a
centrifugal truman show shortly after
alex reaches the entrance which is
heavily guarded by military personnel
that evening he heads to the base of
operations and meets the project manager
hugo hugo takes out his tablet and shows
some statistics to alex which reveals
that there are in fact 10 orbiters he
claims that the progress is good and if
everything proceeds at the same pace the
real launch to celeste may happen in the
next 20 years despite the good news alex
is upset as he worries about the 10 test
subjects that have been isolated in the
orbiters i wonder how many of them he's
coitused however hugo tells him that
sacrificing 10 people for the good of
humanity is the right thing to do at
night as alex is heading home a news
report states that it has been five
years since the celeste spaceship
disaster on that fateful night the space
ship which was carrying 207 crew members
experienced a sudden mechanical failure
just after exiting the earth's surface
this resulted in a fatal crash that
killed everyone on board the head
engineer of the spaceship is revealed to
be none other than alex himself ever
since the incident he has been shrouded
with guilt and sorrow as not only did
several people die but humanity also
suffered a major setback in their quest
to celeste the next morning alex meets
his therapist sylvia who uses a highly
futuristic screen to conduct her
sessions with the help of this screen
people on both sides can't see each
other and even their original voice is
distorted all they can see is a
computerized wolf which resembles their
facial movements unable to hide his
depression anymore alex reveals about
the specifics of his job to sylvia and
explains how he feels bad for the 10
test subjects as days pass by alex
starts getting more and more paranoid he
regularly watches videos and live feeds
of helena implying that he is unable to
shake her from his mind then one day he
finally decides to risk it all he gets
in his car and heads to the facility
meanwhile inside the orbiter 9 as helena
is undergoing her regular health checkup
the alarm starts blaring once again this
surprises helena as her spaceship is far
away from any outpost soon the entrance
door opens and they casually dressed
alex emerges from it he immediately
informs her that they are not in a
spaceship and that they have to escape
but helena who is frozen in fear doesn't
speak a word to prove his point alex
takes out a hidden camera and also a
microchip planted inside helena to track
her vital organs he also tells her that
he is doing this for her safety helena
is still in disbelief but since she has
a crush on alex she agrees to go with
him the science may not check out but my
hormones do before leaving alex hacks
the camera feed and uploads an older
recording of helena so that no one
suspects their escape following this the
two exit the orbiter 9. when helena
steps out of the bunker she is
momentarily dazed and has difficulty
walking as she is experiencing sunlight
and natural air for the first time alex
then hides her inside his truck and
somehow clears her through the entrance
checkup later he stops by a hill and
reveals everything about the orbiter
program and how it came into existence
the program was designed to accustom a
human to space so that the upcoming
launch to celeste can go smoothly he
also informs helena that her parents are
still alive but when the latter
expresses her desire to meet them he
refuses turns out that her parents are
also part of the project shortly after
the two reach alex's home and helena is
surprised to see normal household
equipment she also experiences rain for
the first time and becomes delighted the
following day alex visits sylvia and
informs her of what he's done worried
about her client's safety sylvia shows
her real self to alex and promises to
help him if things go awry that night
alex takes helena out and shows her
around the city he buys a variety of
meals for her something which she has
never experienced in her isolation when
helena talks about the sea he simply
takes her to an aquarium and introduces
her to different fish the next morning
alex leads helena to his private office
where he has a bunch of computers set up
he explains that it is the place from
which he keeps an eye on the orbiters
and tracks their progress clearly
stressed by the breach and privacy
helena asks alex how he could be
involved in such an inhumane act but the
latter replies that it's for the
betterment of humanity with all the data
and statistics gained from the orbiter
project they will be able to flawlessly
send a real spaceship to celeste in the
coming years in the next scene alex
takes helena to a nightclub and
introduces her to his friends one of
them is dr xiao a well-known physician
he asks helena about her hometown but
before she can reply alex makes up an
excuse and diverts the topic he wants to
keep helena's identity a secret at any
cost after a while the group talks about
the implications of the orbiter program
and how it can help humanity in the long
run alex believes that the progress is
good but dr xiao asserts that instead of
finding a new planet people should focus
on making earth a better place one day
alex notices some rashes on helena's
back and takes her to his friend dr xiao
after examining helena on the surface
xiao reveals that her skin is very
sensitive as if she has never been out
in the sun he then sends her for a
thorough checkup and interrogates alex
about her true identity xiao suspects
that she has something to do with the
orbiter program and alex finally reveals
everything that evening while alex is
away helena enters his room and starts
going through his files in one of these
files she finds out something shocking
it turns out that she is not an
offspring after all but actually a clone
she then flips over some pages and finds
the address of her surrogate parents
devastated by the revelation and the
fact that alex lied to her she gathers
her belongings and heads outside to find
her parents later alex arrives at home
and realizes that helena has discovered
the truth about her genetics he is
visibly upset but can do nothing to find
her elsewhere helena finds her parents
and confronts them for abandoning her
the mother who seems to be caring tells
helena that although she is a clone she
has the genetics of people from
different centuries making her extremely
healthy just then the father approaches
helena from behind and cuffs her to the
railing he then proceeds to contact hugo
but surprisingly the mother knocks him
out and helps helena escape a few hours
later she meets up with alex and berates
him for hiding the truth from her with
no words to defend himself alex simply
apologizes and hugs her however the
trouble has just begun realizing that
hugo and his people have gotten wind of
the escape alex and helena pack their
belongings and take off the next day
hugo meets up with the chief benefactor
of the orbiter project catherine and
briefs her about the situation as
expected the boss is far from impressed
as one of her valuable assets has
escaped when hugo asks her for a
solution catherine orders him to find
helena and kill her elsewhere alex takes
helena to her longtime confidant sylvia
and asks for a place to stay being the
kind woman that she is sylvia gladly
accepts but before she can escort them
out she hears a knock at her door
outside she finds hugo and two armed
soldiers on the lookout for helena it
turns out that he rummaged through
alex's apartment and found sylvia's
business card there the men then barge
inside the place and start looking
around soon they reach one of the
therapy booths not realizing that the
couple is on the other side hugo then
orders sylvia to start the screen and as
she does so alex and helena freeze in
their place they do not even blink
because if they do so the wolf
simulation will also move and blow their
cover this goes on for a while and when
sylvia refuses to hand over the couple
one of the soldiers shoots her dead this
terrorizes the couple on the other side
and they immediately run away then an
intense chase ensues on the rooftops
with the couple managing to stay one
step ahead of the bad guys however they
are eventually cornered when they come
across a dead end with no alternative
left alex proposes to jump to another
terrace he goes first but when it's
helena's turn she freezes in fear and is
eventually apprehended alex can do
nothing but watch as hugo and his men
take her away that night a distraught
alex heads to the same nightclub and
approaches his friend xiao who is also
apparently beaten up by hugo and his men
xiao expresses his concern for alex and
also mentions that the test results of
helena are out unfortunately she is
unfit to stay in this environment and
will have to go back inside the orbiter
9 immediately the revelation devastates
alex but an idea strikes his mind in the
meantime hugo approaches catherine and
asks her if he can reinstate helena back
into the orbiter program however she
refuses claiming that it will cost them
a lot of money she then orders him to
finish helena off immediately so that
the news doesn't spread elsewhere
following the orders hugo starts
preparing the euthanization process but
before he can end at all alex arrives
outside the building and proposes a deal
to hugo although the latter has already
made up his mind to kill helena he still
calls alex inside for the sake of their
friendship wasting no time alex mentions
that helena is pregnant with his child a
child which could be of significant
importance in their project he then
proposes that helena be allowed back in
the orbiter alongside him so that they
can both raise their child in the
environment this would create the
perfect astronaut so that after 20 years
he or she can lead the real spaceship to
celeste surprisingly hugo likes the idea
and he lets the couple head back into
the orbiter in the final scene 20 years
have passed by outside orbiter 9 a now
old hugo waits for a girl to come out of
her bunker presumably alex and helena's
daughter the girl smiles at someone
behind her and then looks into the sky
the movie ends as the spaceship ready to
take off for celeste is heard indicating
that the experiment was a success
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching